hey  you have the most perfect wife in my  opinions uh you have these two beautiful  children Alexander and Emma you have  this beautiful career you have this very  very meaningful uh just so needed  Beautiful film coming out ticket to  Paradise you're an activist you have  great friends you've lived an  extraordinary life you saw a particular  company  I was a two-time sexiest man alive yeah  yeah I mean what more can I do  what is the missing link is there one  thing yes  AARP Sexiest Man still alive  I called to be on the cover of AARP and  they were like you have to be 50. I was  like well I'm coming at you in two years  just like wheel me out sexy  every dream you've ever had come true  there's no one more deserving of it than  you George Clooney you are as good as it  gets and thank you for gracing us with  your presence today  [Applause]  there she is  so happy for you thank you  [Music]